one of the deals i did 60 days ago pays
me a hundred thousand dollars a month in
passive income
just by being the bank and so what i
will show you in this video
is how i find these deals how i
structure these deals and
uh one thing to make sure that you don't
do
because actually one of the ceos of the
companies in our portfolio actually
reach out to me
because he got an email from his wealth
advisor i'm gonna use quotes here
because it was almost borderline
unethical what the deal looked like
but i want to walk you through it
because it looks okay but as you
as i show you the framework that i use
which has four four lenses that i look
at investments through
you'll see more and more why it wasn't
good and then at the end i'll show you
what what was good and the deal that
actually made this happen all right
so the deal that his advisor sent him
was
hey we've got a business that wants 450
000
right 450k to invest in their startup
okay so we're sending this money to a
startup
just in case you're curious it's a
little bit risky all right but we'll get
into that in a second
so 450 000 to a startup and he said
they're willing to pay you
10 per year
and they're going to pay this at the end
of 12 months all right
which means at the end of 12 months he's
going to get 450 000
plus 45k all right
that is what the uh return is going to
be all right
and so they were like hey can you break
this down they're like it doesn't sound
like a good deal but we kind of want you
to walk
us through it all right and so here's
how
you should think about these investments
all right
number one is yield
all right which is how much money cash
flow is coming to me every single month
all right that is one way that you look
at the investment
the next way is capital preservation
which is
how likely am i am i going to be
preserving my capital that my money is
going to come back to me
all right all of these are on a scale so
it's not like a yes no it's more like to
what extent
right the next one is tax advantage
all right so if i if i do this
investment
is this going to cost me a lot tax wise
right something that's treated as
capital gains versus something that's
income is going to have a better
tax treatment and then finally you've
got equity growth
all right so does the thing that i'm
buying or putting my money in become
more valuable
all right so when you're looking at any
kind of investment or anywhere to put
your money
look through this lens of one two three
four and think okay
to what extent is my capital being
preserved to what extent am i getting
the yield
what are my tax advantages am i growing
all right and so i walk them through
this exact same process and
so let's look at this deal that you got
all right so capital preservation
box one uh well they're this is going to
a startup and they're saying they're not
going to pay you anything at all and
then at the very end they're going to
give you
uh 495 000 at the end right 450 plus 45
000.
uh how likely do i think that's
happening with a startup i would put
that as an
no probably not likely yield wise i'm
going to get 10
okay that's cash flow kind of good but
for
for a debt deal uh probably not
great all right because we're going to
compare this to is that like
if you look at indexes like the s p i i
don't even know what it was last year
but i'm guessing it was really good it
was probably 20
something like that last year and so
literally
having 100 capital preservation and
having a 20
increase in equities which is here right
you'd have a better return there but
this one has no increase in equities
because we're not participating on the
upside we're just
participating on the downside which by
the way when you ever do money lending
all you get is guaranteed cash and you
participate on the downside so you
really need to make sure the downside is
good
all right and then the fourth box here
is tax advantage these guys make good
money
and so i was like ten percent i was like
you're going to get taxed at
45 right of that 10
which really means your effective
increase is going to be 5.5
all right that's how much you're
actually going to make on this deal
after taxes
that's like barely enough to cover
inflation and so they're saying
risk 450 000 to barely cover inflation
not participate in the upside at all be
tax disadvantaged
and have and do this with a startup so
that you're very unlikely to have your
capital preserved
right so like this is borderline
unethical how bad this deal is
and so what i want to do now if you guys
are good with it is i'll show you the
flip side which is the deal that i just
did
um about 60 days ago all right so here's
how this deal worked
i wrote a note for 2.5 million dollars
all right
uh to secure a building out of
foreclosure all right so
somebody emailed me and said hey um i
found this building
it's two uh it's 2.5 million dollars
that's how much i can buy it for
and i said okay well tell me more about
this deal
so we're going through the same
framework all right so we've got
capital preservation we've got yield
we've got tax and we've got equity all
right
so in this in this situation um he then
said
i have four offers
on the building already between 5.1
and 5.6 million all right and i was like
okay so now i know that this is
reasonable and he sent me the offers
over so i knew that they were good on
top of that
they had taken the top guy and this guy
had put 300 000
in earnest money down meaning he had
committed to doing the deal as soon as
he
as soon as it comes available all right
so we have a real buyer lined up at 5.6
million sounds good so far and this
building is worth 2.5 so i'm thinking
capital reservation if if for some
reason this deal goes through
i've got three other people who've said
they've been willing to give
more than twice as much money as i'm
buying this for all right
pretty good now mind you i'm not buying
the building i'm the bank here i'm the
one lending the money to the guy
all right now he's gonna make good money
on this he's gonna
get two and a half million that's not
his money and then he's gonna sell it
for 5.1 to 5.6 in this case 5.6 and he's
going to end up making 2.1 million on
this deal
minus whatever my fee is for supplying
the money
now on top of that i asked to have a
personal guarantee
from him and the partner all right so
just in case
these three offers fall through on top
of the fourth offer with the earnest
money
i got personal guarantees by both the
buyers of the building
all right so this is how i wanted to
make sure that my capital is preserved
so i'm like cool check now do i
participate in
any of the equity of this of this
business
the answer is none i don't have any
equity participation from a tax
perspective
if they're just going to pay me a yield
which is exactly how i structured it
what am i going to have bad tax
treatment you bet your ass i am
it's going to be treated as regular
income so it's got to be really worth it
for me on the yield side
and so the way that i wrote the note is
i get 48
to 96 per year
you're like how can you achieve you know
uh returns like that
if you look for them right that's the
simple answer right and the more deals
you do the more people know that you
have money that you can do deals and
then the more they reach out to you
right
and if there's not a lot of people who
can just snap a hat and just throw out
two and a half million dollars and so
you get on a higher and higher list and
you get access to different deals all
right that's the short answer
so what they're doing here is that means
that i'm getting four percent
per month all right now if you do the
math on two and a half million four
percent per month
is a hundred thousand dollars per month
now
you might be wondering why would anyone
pay that this is a bridge loan
this is a short-term loan it's called
hard money lending
private lending private placement
different things like that but they need
money
fast and so they can't go through a
normal process because they got a
steal on this building right how many
times you get a building for two and a
half that's worth five
immediately right not many and so they
need someone who can immediately provide
liquidity
and in exchange they pay a higher rate
now they're not planning on holding the
money for the whole year
but if i do multiple deals like this
then i can effectively get a rate that's
comparable to this
over the time period of the year all
right so four percent per month that's a
hundred thousand dollars a month
their planned holding time was going to
be 60 days
i gave them 90 days at this which means
in the minimum carry meaning if they did
it in
two in 24 hours i still get two months
of minimum carry meaning if i'm gonna do
this deal
i have to make at least two hundred
thousand dollars on just sending the
wire and then getting the money back
even if it takes
a day like it doesn't matter all right
so i set up a minimum carry for that
of of times two i'm giving them up to 90
days
where they can continue to pay and if
it's like 65 days it still rolls into
three months
right which means then i'm at like three
times this right which is 300 000
and so sometimes when people were like
why aren't you selling stuff on this
channel
it's because um i don't really care and
so
hopefully this makes sense to you if
you're thinking if someone emails you
god i hope they don't email you but if
someone emails you a deal that looks
like this one run the other
way and you know question their morals
and ethics because either they
absolutely
absolutely have no idea what they're
doing or they're expecting that you have
no idea what you're doing
and so that is why i'm making this video
so that you don't do a deal like this
you think through it through within uh
these
these four levels and there is a point
because i know i'm going to get this
question
well at what percentage is it worth
getting the yield which is this fourth
box here right
well i'm going to get taxed on this
right at
my after tax rate on this is going to be
like 27
return so for me 27 return still makes
sense after taxes and everything
um so that that deal makes sense but it
has to be really really good for me
because i have a ton of income
so i'm gonna get taxed at the highest
bracket if it's any kind of regular
income type deal
and so if you're gonna do a deal like
this you have to make sure that it makes
sense
all right so hopefully that makes sense
to you guys hope you enjoyed that
uh like subscribe all that stuff and
i'll see you guys next video